[Música]
son las 8:31 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
diciendo nocturna seguimos comentándoles
los principales hechos del día Les
agradecemos su sintonía vamos con los
titulares de esta jornada
el gobierno de Polonia atribuyó a un
misil de fabricación rusa la explosión
ocurrida en el este del país cerca de la
frontera con Ucrania Varsovia llamó a
consultas al embajador ruso ruso en
alerta sus fuerzas armadas y está
evaluando consultar a sus socios de la
otan si se trata de un ataque a su
territorio
Estados Unidos está la expectativa ante
el posible anuncio de la candidatura a
la presidencia que podría hacer el ex
presidente Donald Trump pese a las
investigaciones y causas legales en su
contra ya que los republicanos No
tuvieron el desempeño esperado en las
recientes elecciones de medio término
ampliamos con nuestro corresponsal en
Washington
Gustavo Petro el primer presidente de
izquierda de Colombia cumplió sus
primeros 100 días en el cargo el período
ha estado marcado por el
restablecimiento de las relaciones con
Venezuela y su defensa de la paz total
pero se ha visto ensombrecido por la
difícil situación económica del país
analizamos en esta emisión
[Aplausos]
[Música]
iniciamos en Polonia porque el gobierno
atribuyó a un misil de fabricación rusa
la explosión registrada en el distrito
de dublín en el este del país muy cerca
de la frontera con Ucrania el estallido
provocó la muerte de dos personas por lo
que Varsovia convocó al embajador ruso
destacando ante el gobierno polaco tras
una reunión del Consejo de Seguridad las
autoridades anunciaron la apuesta en
alerta de las fuerzas armadas y se
estudian consultas a los socios de la
otan para determinar si dicha detonación
es considerada como una amenaza a su
territorio el presidente de Polonia
Android duda dijo que es muy probable
que su país active el artículo 4 de la
carta de la otan este miércoles en una
reunión de urgencia
hemos decidido Llamar al embajador de la
federación rusa al Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores el ministro de
relaciones exteriores hablará pronto con
el embajador ruso
nos mantenemos en contacto con el
gobierno de Ucrania el señor presidente
habló con el señor presidente celensky
estoy en contacto con el Primer Ministro
de Ucrania
en respuesta a Rusia negó que haya
realizado ataques en la zona fronteriza
donde ocurrieron los hechos el portavoz
del kremlin dimitrip Scott dijo no tener
información sobre el incidente por su
parte Estados Unidos se muestra cauto
ante los señalamientos contra Rusia y el
pentágono informó estar evaluando la
situación por el contrario el presidente
de Ucrania culpó directamente a Moscú
del ataque
somos conscientes de los informes de
prensa que alegan que dos misiles rusos
han impactado en un lugar dentro de
Polonia cerca la frontera con Ucrania
puede decirles que no tenemos ninguna
información en este momento para
corroborar esos informes y estamos
investigando esto más a fondo Así que
cuando tengamos una actualización para
proporcionar nos aseguraremos de hacerlo
Polonia los estados bálticos es solo
cuestión de tiempo antes de que el
terror ruso vaya más allá Es necesario
poner al terrorista en su lugar Cuanto
más tiempo sienta a Rusia la impunidad
más amenazas habrá para todos los que
puedan ser alcanzados por misiles rusos
entre tanto las autoridades ucranianas
aseguraron que Rusia lanzó Este martes
un centenar de misiles provocando
apagones a lo largo y ancho del país en
un ataque que catalogaron como el mayor
desde que comenzó la guerra 8 millones
de usuarios quedaron sin servicio de
elec que luego fue reconectado los
bombardeos llegan pocos días después de
que Ucrania retomara el control de la
región de gerson Manuela Cano con los
detalles
cerca de un centenar de misiles
rompieron la aparente calma que reinaba
en territorio ucraniano Rusia
contraatacó días después de que las
fuerzas de kiev recuperaran la región de
gersón selensky advirtió que los
bombardeos podrían continuar una decena
de ciudades fueron tocadas por lo que
Ucrania denominó como la mayor ola de
ataques desde que se desató la guerra
se lanzaron 85 ataques con misiles
contra Ucrania contra nuestras ciudades
principalmente en la infraestructura
energética está claro lo que quiere el
enemigo no logrará su objetivo
estamos trabajando restauraremos todo
sobreviviremos a todo Gloria a Ucrania
lo estás haciendo muy bien
Jeff sufrió los efectos de los
bombardeos que chocaron contra
apartamentos residenciales
sentí la explosión luego vi el humo
corría al balcón para ver de dónde venía
el humo al principio Pensé que podría
ser una explosión de gas y entrada de la
noche y la oscuridad se apoderó de nuevo
de las calles de la capital debido a
cortes de energía por la infraestructura
eléctrica afectada
creemos que nadie debería hacer esto
especialmente en nuestros vecinos
esperemos que ganemos Gloria a las
fuerzas armadas de Ucrania los ataques
llegan el mismo día en que los miembros
del g20 se reunieron para discutir la
guerra en Ucrania en la que múltiples
países se preparan para dar una
declaración conjunta en contra de la
invasión rusa Estados Unidos condenó
rotundamente La ola de ataques y aseguró
que solo servirán para aumentar las
preocupaciones del grupo cambiamos de
tema y vamos a Estados Unidos El
republicano Kevin mccarthy fue elegido
nuevamente como líder de su partido en
la cámara de representantes del Congreso
de esta manera mccarthy queda en una
posición privilegiada para convertirse
en el presidente de ese órgano
legislativo en sustitución de la
demócrata Nancy pelosi sí Se confirma la
mayoría republicana en la cámara el
representante fue elegido en una
votación secreta de su partido con lo
que inicia una campaña de cara al
plenario del 3 de enero cuando a los 435
integrantes de la cámara baja escojan a
un presidente
y hay expectativa en Estados Unidos por
el anuncio que podría realizar el ex
presidente de ese país Donald Trump
quien podría anunciar de manera oficial
su intención de ser nuevamente candidato
por el partido republicano para regresar
a la presidencia del país previamente
conversamos con Cristóbal Vázquez
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense que nos dijo porque
insiste Trump en lanzar su candidatura
justo después de las elecciones de medio
mandato
Sí y a pesar incluso de que senadores
republicanos como Paty tube y de
Pensilvania diga que el partido
republicano ya tiene que superar a
Donald Trump y que otras figuras
importantes del partido digan
públicamente que hay que pensar en otros
políticos de Cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del 2024 Donald Trump
existe y hará este discurso hoy
alrededor de las nueve de la noche desde
la Florida desde su mansión en mara lago
insiste en parte porque sabe que todavía
tiene la atención mediática y Porque
todavía tiene bastante poder político
dentro de su partido dentro de la
facción maga make América greatest que
son los republicanos más de corte
conservador más radicales además pues no
quiere que sus rivales políticos
republicanos sigan ganando terrenos
siguen ganando más protagonismo esto le
podría perjudicar en su interés de
volver a llegar a la casa blanca y en
tercera medida porque sabe que tiene
pues investigaciones en su contra estas
investigaciones investigaciones Se
podrían demorar de de Cara a su
candidatura es decir como candidato el
departamento de Justicia tendría pues
más dificultades en avanzar en la
investigación que se le lleva a cabo por
su vínculo posible vínculo en los en La
Toma Capitolio el 6 de enero del 2021 y
también por haberse llevado información
confidencial de la Casa Blanca
precisamente a su mansión en maralá
continuamos en la Unión Americana porque
un juez Federal bloqueó el título 42 una
norma que permitía las autoridades
expulsar a migrantes indocumentados
utilizando la pandemia como
justificación según la justicia la
normativa es arbitraria y caprichosa y
el bloqueo entra en vigor de forma
inmediata el título 42 comenzó a
aplicarse en 2020 durante la
administración Trump y se ha mantenido
durante el gobierno de Joe biden desde
marzo 2020 Cuando entró en vigor
alrededor de 2,4 millones de importantes
han sido repatriados
este 15 de noviembre se cumplieron los
primeros 100 días de Gustavo Petro al
frente de la presidencia de Colombia
entre los que se consideran sus grandes
logros en este tiempo están conseguir la
aprobación de la ley de paz total y
restablecer las relaciones con Venezuela
no obstante la devaluación del peso
colombiano y la falta de integración
dentro de su gobierno han ensombrecido
este periodo para analizar la situación
del mandatario del país conectamos con
Andrés Dávila profesor del departamento
de ciencia política de la Universidad
javeriana de Colombia Bienvenido a
France 24 Cómo está la imagen del primer
presidente de izquierda de Colombia
tanto dentro del país como fuera que
balance se puede hacer
Bueno yo creo que ese pronto para hacer
un balance muy sustantivo pero sin duda
hay algunas
aspectos de su gestión que muestran
resultados interesantes además de los
que usted mencionó yo agregaría pues El
Avance en la reforma tributaria y sin
duda en una agenda reformista importante
Pero claro con una situación económica y
unas condiciones de de ciertos
indicadores de la economía que preocupan
y que afectan a la sociedad colombiana
estamos en ese proceso complejo en que
falta ver también Hacia dónde avanzamos
con el plan Nacional de desarrollo en el
cual digamos ya se entregaron las bases
del plan de acuerdo con lo previsto en
la ley y en una agenda que que vamos a
ver cómo se termina de concretar luego
de tantos intentos y de tantos anuncios
de reformas de fondo bueno y le preguntó
de todas formas Cómo está la imagen del
mandatario dentro del país y la imagen
en América Latina yo creo que a nivel de
América Latina pues obviamente en
algunos países bien porque ahí acogía a
su a sus propuestas porque hay
coincidencia política en otros no tanto
cuando hay rivalidad y y distancia
ideológica pues evidentemente no a nivel
interno creo que hay que mirarlo bien en
de qué sectores se han mantenido la
favorabilidad hacia el presidente y a su
gobierno y qué sectores se han ido
alejando que yo creería que están muy de
la mano de los sectores de centro de las
élites tradicionales que no logran
aceptar las propuestas de Petro
adecuadamente pero es una cuestión que
hay que ir midiendo muy mesa mes a ver
cómo se dan las condiciones de
gobernabilidad y de favorabilidad del
presidente que creo en todo caso
comparadas con las de Iván Duque Hace
cuatro años pues por lo pronto lo hacen
ver mejor en la mirada general
justamente usted lo estaba diciendo el
presidente tiene diferentes vistas
diferentes imágenes dependiendo del
sector de la sociedad del que se hable
con lo visto hasta ahora se puede pensar
que Petro sea una figura que pueda unir
de alguna manera a la sociedad
colombiana
es difícil primero por las condiciones
en que fue electo en donde el medio país
lo apoyó y medio país es voto por por su
rival sin embargo creo que ha ganado
algunos nichos o alguna confianza en
algunos sectores pero sin duda también
tiene opositores
No solo en el terreno político sino
ideológico y como de
la aceptación a su personalidad que
hacen ella porque salen siempre con con
digamos posiciones muy opuestas a todo
lo que significa Petro yo creo que eso
va a ser una atención a lo largo de los
cuatro años y que tendremos que estar
pendientes de qué tanto logra Yo diría
que en el fondo correr este sistema
político tan cargado al centro derecha
correrlo un poquito hacia el centro ni
siquiera vivía centro izquierda hacia el
centro pero es una tarea larga
dispendiosa y que habrá que ver también
del desempeño que se presente en todas
las áreas de su de su gobierno pues
señor David usted muchas gracias por su
análisis y por compartirlo en 24 un
gusto muy amables nos vamos ahora hasta
Egipto después de una semana de
negociaciones climáticas los gobiernos
de América Latina y el Caribe dieron a
conocer su posición con los discursos de
los ministros en la cop 27 una de las
intervenciones fue la de México que
renovó sus contribuciones para reducir
las emisiones de gases de efecto
invernadero al pasar de la meta de bajar
22% a un 35%. también aspira duplicar su
producción de energías limpias desde
Charmander nuestra enviada especial
María Clara calle nos cuenta más de las
posturas que tuvieron los latinos
día de países latinoamericanos en la cop
27 con más de una decena de ministros
hablando y a pesar de las diferencias
ideológicas hubo un llamado al unísono
exigirle a los países más desarrollados
que cumplan con la financiación para
combatir la crisis climática por ejemplo
Argentina y Nicaragua recordaron que es
necesario que los más industrializados
cumplan su promesa de dar 100 mil
millones de dólares anuales a los más
vulnerables mientras que Ecuador pidió
que esto no sea a manera de deuda México
por su parte habló de indemnizaciones
para referirse al mecanismo de pérdidas
y daños indemnizaciones es una palabra
que los desarrollados prefieren evitar
para no abrir demandas legales mientras
que República Dominicana dijo que no se
trataba de Caridad sino de justicia y
que sin este mecanismo no habría un
acuerdo en charmershake Argentina
Ecuador y chile le pidieron a los más
desarrollados que más ambiciosos al
cumplir y al establecer sus metas
climáticas por su parte el ministro
brasileño Joaquín Pereira se concentró
en defender las labores del saliente
Yair bolsonaron al decir que sí son un
gobierno ambiental por producir
hidrógeno y amoniaco verde y al decir
que contrario a lo que hicieron
gobiernos pasados ellos no se dedicaron
a multar y a perseguir sino hacer
alianzas con los privados sin embargo no
mencionó que bajo el mandato de
bolsonaro la deforestación en la
amazonía aumentó un 73% según los datos
oficiales del inpe y todo esto ocurre A
pocas horas de que el presidente electo
Lula da Silva se pronuncie en la copa ya
habló con los enviados climáticos de
Estados Unidos y China y mañana se
reunirá con seis de los nueve
gobernadores amazónicos de Brasil y
también dará su discurso en el que se
espera que ponga a Brasil de nuevo en el
centro ambiental
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía los
invitamos a continuar con nosotros que
ya llega herminia Fernández Con toda la
información de nuestra red de
corresponsales en el mundo feliz noche
para todos
[Música]